[موسيقى]
ممكن التاسي راح يكون باوند راح يكون في
حاله تدبلج على خلف الربع الاول
ممكن يكون في النصف الثاني لا اغلب
الاهتمام
بعد
حجم كاسات العالميه الاستهلاك العالمي
اتفق اخترنا عده قطاع غزه
اثناء انقطاع المصري
احنا في نظرتنا انه ارتفاع اسعار الفائده
بالذات الي صار شار في سبتمبر بدا بارتفاع
كبير صاحبه صحيح قوي في السوق السعودي حتى
الان مستوى اسعار الفائده من التراوح ما
بين 56 الفيدراليه زي ما ذكر امس بوم
برفع مرتين ب 25 نقطه ثم يكون يقيم
الاوضاع غالبا اغلب السيناريو انه فعلا
بدا يصير انخفض لها اكثر ما يكون في تراجع
او انه فتره الاسعار الفائده راح تكون
قصيره لا علينا ان نكون واقعيين ممكن ان
انت تمتد الى سنتين
فهذا الشيء الاول وارتفاع اسعار الفائده
اللي ادت تصحيح السوق السعودي اسعار
البترول ميزانيه السعوديه في تقديرناها
اخذت في سعر 78$ الحين اتوقع اسعار
البترول ممكن تكون 80 85$